hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I was just
getting blown up with notifications
while in the middle of filming a video
and sure enough it's finally here what
we've been waiting for the Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice Comic Con
trailer more like comic-con trailer
today is a day for truth beautiful the
world needs to know what happened and to
know what he stands for that kind of
power is very dangerous
let the record show that this committee
holds him responsible
that's how it starts the fever the rage
but turns good men cruel this bat
vigilante is like a one-man right of
terror you don't get to decide what the
right thing is nobody cares about Clark
Kent oh my god sir exciting carefully
this badly it's all some people have
it's all that gives them hope
people hate what they don't understand
be their hero either angel Peter
monuments
anything they need you think
you don't know this worldís thing you
never did do you know the oldest lie in
America senator
The Devil's don't come from Hell beneath
us
they come from the sky
twenty years in Gotham how many good
guys are rough
and they stayed that way he has the
power to wipe out the entire human race
Wow
[ __ ] man I'm gonna have to destroy
you go to war
he is not
black and blue
God versus man
day versus night
the red capes circling the red capes are
coming
haha
oh my god baby come over here right now
put some pants on
just come here put your pants on
you got to watch this trailer with me
baby you gotta watch this trailer with
me okay you look like you're from
Compton right now hey Dad yes all right
watch his trailer got cool his movie
looks
she's probably be nowhere near as
excited as me
today is a day for truth illegal ilium
the world needs to know what happened
and to know what he stands for that kind
of power is very dangerous
does it look shot beautifully breathe
everyone's running away let the record
show that this committee holds him
responsible
because how it starts the fever the
Delrin this bad vigilantes like a
one-man right of terror you don't get to
decide what the right thing is nobody
cares about Clark Kent taking on the
Batman all some people have ever give
some
people hate what they don't understand
be their hero either an angel
Peter monuments
anything they need you
I'll be on it
you don't know this worldís thing you
never did you know the oldest lie in
America senator the devil's don't come
from Hell beneath us
they come from the sky
twenty years in Gotham I made good guns
or left
I'm going to stay that way he has the
power to wipe out the entire human race
so that look like it's
I'm gonna have to destroy
he is not our enemy
prove tonight
black and blue
gone versus man
day versus night
the red capes circling the red capes are
coming coming
and and versus Superman dawn of Justice
dear granny fighting they said it in the
trailer I don't so okay that man thinks
that Superman is bad well he's saying
that he has the power to wipe out the
whole human race and I believe at this
particular trust she doesn't nearly know
about the comics and or the movies and
stuff lately she but she has seen the
Dark Knight trilogy remember a Man of
Steel how like all that destruction
happened in Metropolis at the end of the
film from what this trailer showing us
Bruce Wayne is like this guy's a threat
he could wipe out the whole human race
and I think Superman's actions have
probably led to some of Batman's old
criminals coming out again because
there's a movie coming out called
Suicide Squad this is cool talking yeah
is what we do all the time on our own
because I just constantly talk to her
about movies and what's going on there's
a movie called Suicide Squad coming out
which is like a bunch of Batman villains
all together and the Joker's part of it
is for Jared Leto's coming in and so you
know they were seeing stuff that Joker
clearly wrote like on the Batsuit and
stuff joke's on you Batman I'm pretty
sure that it's now Batman a little bit
after he's been Batman or he like
retired for a bit now he's coming out of
retirement because that's how one of the
comics goes and now the people want him
to be on their side and help that's not
clear yet but there are obviously a war
a debate going on between Superman being
a hero or being something to fear like
that's why at the beginning they were
like illegal alien and well it's mating
on him I know but it makes sense because
in Man of Steel none of that would have
happened if it weren't for any of the
Kryptonians you know like Superman came
he read the general zod came over to
earth and then the battle happened
between them Kryptonians are dangerous
[ __ ] so when exactly is it coming out
they don't have a set date it's just in
next year I don't have a set day I think
it's Juna so I figure out the month
first off just the way it's shot looks
great you know like Man of Steel if you
remember I know alien saw it once but it
was so handheld this film looks
smoothly captured that the imagery looks
similar more to like what we've seen
Zack Snyder do and movies like 300 and
Watchmen there's more of a striking
visual beautiful image dramatic
yeah very dramatic very cinematic I love
what we're seeing with Ben Affleck as
Bruce Wayne I'm really enjoying it like
he that the anger looks real it looks
like there's a real kind of trauma and
terror inside of him that really wants
to come out his interaction with Alfred
looks [ __ ] awesome because Alfred is
kind of looks like a badass Butler who
like takes care of him well how did you
see that why I haven't seen many of
these trailers but I didn't really see
much of Alfred there's like a tiny
little yeah it's very small but the
little bits you get you could tell this
guy he seems more like a tough Alfred
Frank Miller comics this is based off of
a lot of the that Alfred portrayal si
can be rather tough he's a former I
think he's like former person part of
the military or some [ __ ] it's cool to
see that we're getting like a tougher
Alfred the one thing I'm concerned about
one concern Oh what is it Jesse
Eisenberg is lucky yeah you know he was
the only one that I wasn't really
believing his Lex Luthor is Superman's
arch nemesis so I'm assuming in this
movie Batman and Superman are eventually
going to come together to take down Lex
Luthor in some way that's what I'm
assuming the Lex Luthor like there was a
lot of controversy over this casting
because it's like we can't buy Jesse
Eisenberg as Lex Luthor and I'm like
come on give the guy a chance he's got
an Academy Award nomination now that
I've seen some of the clips I'm like ah
very intimidating that it doesn't seem
he's not intimidating sure he seems a
little creepy but it's just the trailer
so you know you got to see the whole
thing in its context but I was still
having a hard time buying him but like
just Ben Affleck though it's like I've
seen Ben Affleck a billion times playing
Ben athlete but I was buying him as
Bruce Wayne but Jesse Eisenberg I was
like oh it doesn't really it seems like
he's acting like it didn't match the
rest of the he seems like he's out of a
different comic book movie you know like
he's playing a comic book role but
that's very few seconds so yeah we'll
see you
No
if you guys are new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can check out Veronica's channel
acoustic covers on there check it out
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter vine and I just got a periscope
oh so many social networks what's the
point of all them to get product
placement that's right more product
placement for things such as that's
actually really cool it's it's a
homemade um snow globe it's made of snow
well there's glitter in it it's it's a
but it's clearly doesn't make me shade
it's my little cousins project Oh your
little cousin me this you couldn't make
something like that I could so make
something like this you can feel sorry
for little cousins and help them out by
giving them some money for this that was
really we i guess i'm promoting charity
at this time okay
well i can go that donate your money
idiots do that oh shut up you donated 20
bucks
last week that's all i've done it